be first Fear and Loathing at 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue a new political
report now claiming that Biden is
frustrated and anxious and mad about his
son's legal woes even lashing out at
White House AIDS blasting even his own
AG Merrick Garland for allowing his son
to be charged with a crime there is also
deep Panic surrounding the president's
looming impeachment inquiry and in Iran
purportedly written by Joe Biden the
president is accusing Republicans of
quote attacking me with lies instead of
doing their job on the Urgent work that
needs to be done they are choosing to
waste time on this baseless political
stunt well apparently House Republicans
struck a nerve including right here on
this program last night you got this uh
Biden snake likee spokesperson Ian
sams's his name I don't know apparently
he works in the White House council's
office apparently he's a spokesperson of
some kind
but also he was very busy last night
reacting to this show and at one point
tweeting out uh that quote house for
Republican leaders again I quote aren't
pursuing anything real they are just
using it as a political stunt to go to
places like Hannity to relentlessly
attack a good and honorable man with
lies okay Mr Sams you mean the good
honorable man the one that wouldn't
acknowledge his own granddaughter for
years his son wouldn't acknowledge his
own daughter for a long period of time
you might want to explain to us Mr Sam's
exactly what services that zero
experience Hunter rendered to be paid
millions and millions of dollars from a
Ukrainian and a Chinese Energy company
both companies uh when he admitted
himself in his own words that he had no
experience in energy at all at the time
that he was also struggling with very
serious addiction issues why why would a
vice president of our country our great
country why would a vice president
leverage 1 billion taxpayer dollars Mr
Sam's to have a Ukrainian prosecutor
fired does that seem odd to you that
action by the way resulted in his
inexperienced son being paid even more
money for a business that he had no
experience in why would Hunter Biden be
threatening a Chinese business partner
on a WhatsApp message with retribution
from his father and everybody is he
knows and his ability to hold a grudge
if they didn't get paid uh what you know
was he sitting with his father at the
time of the message because that's what
the message uh actually says and why did
Joe Biden lie repeatedly when he said
over and over and over again that he
never one time ever discussed his
foreign business deals with Hunter his
brother or anybody for that matter would
you now acknowledge Mr Sams that that is
a lie there is now photographic evidence
that Joe Biden met with Hunter and his
foreign business partners and testimony
that Joe Biden was on the phone with at
least 20 of on at least 20 calls with
Hunter and his foreign business partners
oh did Joe lie lastly I have a really
important question is Joe Biden the big
guy as Tony balinsky has told us now
when you Mr Sams when you answer these
simple questions I've got a hundred more
here's what we're going to do we invited
you on the program tonight we got no
response so Mr Sams let me extend an
invitation again very publicly you can
come on my radio show and
735 of the greatest radio stations in
the country I'll give you the full three
hours to be my guest and as a bonus you
can come on this TV show I will give you
a full hour instead of you just hiding
behind your desk at the Biden White
House sending out your little tweets on
x of course Ian Sams is more than happy
to take softball questions on his
favorite networks like fake news CNN
he's been on msdnc you're welcome here
Mr Sams come on for the full hour I have
a list of questions that I really really
would like to ask you and hear your
answers on but take a look so they're
just making up lies to attack the
president in a Relentless smear campaign
that frankly has been going on for four
straight years now we've been extremely
clear over and over again for years and
nothing has changed the president was
not in business with his son period
they're trying to make up all sorts of
allegations and make up lies I'm not
citing Jim Jordan here I was in some of
the White House Press briefings where it
was said explicitly the president did
not talk to his son about business
dealing that that is very clearly not
the case and I think the statement from
the White House has changed uh and I
think been a little bit more precise
over the course of the last several
months it's what the president said on
the campaign Trail as well I'm not
saying this is like an impeachable
offense or uh some Grand uh indictment
but it is a fact that the president said
one thing that ended up being not
true again I dispute that that's that
that's true that is not true the truth
is that he wasn't in business with his
son all right it is sad to see someone
make a fool out of themselves on
national TV now this Ian Sam's person is
either living in a fantasy world or just
lying to your face but the American
people you have a choice you can believe
a quivering no-name partisan hack or or
you can put your trust in two
nonpartisan government whistleblowers
one a Democrat with nothing to gain and
everything to lose and today by the way
those two IRS whistleblowers said that
there was ample evidence to show that
your President Joe Biden was involved in
his son's business deals take a look for
yourself uh at the beginning it was I've
never talked to my son about business
that's been uh proven patently false by
evidence and testimony we' provided uh
then it moved he's not in business with
him and uh now we're into he's not
financially uh connected to to the
businesses so uh you you don't have to
be financially uh uh connected to a
business in order to uh be a part of
that business and what what President
Biden was was uh basically doing through
Hunter Biden was allowing Hunter Biden
to get these deals where there's no
discernable actual product being
produced so it's really just a pedaling
of uh of the influence now again these
two IRS investigators they risked
everything to come forward their claims
about hunter's alleged crimes were just
proven True by a Federal indictment and
their new claims about Joe Biden's
involvement in the Biden family business
well guess what they're backed up with
pictures eyewitness testimony uh they
are backed up by suspicious activity
reports allegations from credible
government Source detailed in that FBI
1023 form along with phone records and
texts and emails and even a handwritten
note well on the other side you have Joe
Biden who wants you to just simply trust
him now Joe has previously lied about
let's see his past employment his grades
in law school his trips on am Amtrak the
death of his own son his actions after
911 his role in the Civil Rights
Movement his non-existent arrest in
South Africa his house getting destroyed
by a fire that wasn't true his totally P
Southern border and the number of even
grandchildren he has in his own family
and again Biden also well definitely
lied when he said he never ever once
interacted with hunter or his brother or
any of their foreign business partners
now meanwhile the B Biden family bagman
Hunter is also deeply dishonest the
Apple really doesn't fall far from the
tree like father like son Hunter is now
federally accused of lying on his taxes
lying about deductions lying on a gun
application but we're all what supposed
to believe that the millions that he was
making from Russia and Ukraine in China
and Romania and elsewhere you know are
all without any relevant experience that
that really was on the up and up we're
supposed to believe that that you get
millions of dollars no experience at all
by your own admission at a time in your
life when you're struggling with
addiction now in what is almost too
crazy to be true we got Hunter and Joe
now teaming up with Congressman Eric
swalwell remember him Fang Fang Fame but
anyway to prove their innocence ahead of
a possible impeachment now swalwell
helped Hunter orchestrate yesterday's
little PR stunt outside the Capal the
very same Eric swell who kicked off the
house intelligence committee because of
an alleged romantic affair with a
Chinese spy yep the name you can't make
it up in a novel fangfang but the media
mob they don't seem to care the White
House press Corp well they barely asked
about the impeachment vote today and the
New York Times They were running cover
for Joe Biden actually leaving out the
very key word in its report about
hunter's rant on Capitol Hill when he
said that his father was never
financially involved in his business so
why would the New York Times omit the
word financially so they wouldn't have
to what explain the evolution of the
Biden family and all the lies that
they've told hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else